hello i'm here with Malcolm pain the
organizer of the London chess classic
the third leg in the grand chest or now
Malcolm and I we have quite a history
going back a whole year now working on
this grand chest or Malcolm can you tell
me what your thoughts on the inaugural
year how it went and what your thoughts
are moving forward well I think we've
had two fantastic tournaments already in
Norway in st. Louis the London chess
classic is well a great honor is honored
really to climb a cat the tall and the
tall standings of course change with
every round which is quite nice I think
that very very often in a tournament you
know you get someone who's in the lead
and they kind of they might stay there
you don't it doesn't necessarily
fluctuate but actually I've been looking
at the tall standings and they they
fluctuate every day which is really
really nice there's a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars of prize money at stake
in addition to the the 300,000 here and
I think the players are playing probably
for the biggest money of the year
outside the world championship so you
know it gives the crowd an extra an
extra thing to think about as well and
the take-up has been well the take-up as
beat as being quite interesting I lots
of people asking me how does it work how
many points that they get so I'm able to
point them towards this wonderful
website that you've set up and I'm
really excited about doing it next year
you know the grand chest or the players
are competing for a million dollars
overall between the three events and the
the tour prize do you think that that's
enough and if not what do you want to
see the Grand chest or grow to be well a
million dollars in in certainly and
chest terms is great but I don't like to
think in terms of what the chess world
where the chess world is currently you
know I think we've got ambitions to make
it much bigger than that to have a name
sponsor put in a bit more money to the
Grand chest or what I'm pleased about
though is that actually the prime the
prize money at London has been brought
up it's been increased by being part of
the tour and I think that's very good
the fact that the tour is if you like
raising standards both for the
professionals and also for the
spectators which is what it's all about
and you know there have been other
attempts at series of tournaments like
this the feed a Grand Prix series and
there was the Grandmaster slam that
existed in the past as well what's
unique about the grand chest or that
will make it stand the test of time and
and and a garter all of those great
things that you mentioned yeah I mean I
think that the the grand slam masters
was quite a nice idea
when it was worked out but it never
really had in everybody had stability
and we'll never really understood
exactly white players were in some other
tournaments sometimes it was obvious
sometimes it wasn't so clear I think the
good thing and I think it's essential
for any structure like this is that the
Grand Tour is very clearly defined rules
and so you'll know immediately at the
end of the 2015 Grand Tour who's playing
in the 2016 grant or should I say who's
being invited I think I think that's
essential as for the feed a grand prix
well they were quite nice tolerance but
they didn't have it was almost like it
was like division to you know it was
that it wasn't major league I wasn't
Premier League it was the players below
the very top so the great thing about
the Grand Tour is that it has the prize
money the conditions and the attraction
for the very very top players he heard
it here first ladies and gentlemen the
grand chest or 2016 promises to be
better than any of the tours that have
existed in the past including this year
thank you very much Malcolm